due to health restrictions and the lack
of a studio audience
we haven't been able to have stand-up
comics perform on our show
during the pandemic so i thought what if
i sent a cameraman
to their homes to safely shoot them from
a distance
here were the messages to some of you
out there it's a very funny gentleman
calvin evans calvin i'm from chicago
but i've been quarantined in l.a and i
see a lot of plastic surgery i'm gonna
say this
not a fan of it now don't get me wrong
if you had like an accident they just
putting something back the way it was
i completely understand but if you're
doing it for vanity reasons not a fan of
it
and the reason is i feel like we need
ugly people
now i'm not saying that in a messed up
way i feel like ugly people
advance society by leaps and bounds
think about all the greatest people in
history
they all been ugly beautiful people that
don't do anything they just reap the
benefits of being beautiful and we
accept them at face value literally
like for instance angelina jolie
gorgeous woman she's so gorgeous her
entire career nobody ever said to her
hey
your lip's chapped they was like you
know what don't even worry about it just
keep being beautiful
but ugly people got to do amazing things
to reap those same benefits
like for instance steve jobs weird ugly
looking dude wear glasses
he's sitting around thinking himself
what if cause that's what you gotta do
when you ugly you gotta think about
stuff that don't exist
so people can like you he was like what
if what if i had all my music in my
pocket
we got ipods and ipads changed how we
even
understand cell phones he would have
never thought of that if he was having
sex with somebody
jeff bezos bald head weird-looking dude
he's sitting around his house
thinking about what if i could just stay
my ugly ass at home and shop
we got amazon changed the way we shop do
you understand what i'm saying do y'all
think if harry tubman was beautiful she
would have saved as many slaves as she
did
no don't do that don't do that if harry
tubman was beautiful she'd be a footnote
in the history books about some slay
that had a bunch of mixed kids
but she wasn't she was ugly and she was
enslaved
and she was looking around she was like
yo what if i left
and she did she left she came back she
left she came back she saved hundreds
thousands of slaves that was so
unprecedented at the time
we forgot how she looked and almost put
on a twenty dollar bill
and then they printed the tony out it
was like yo who the hell is this is this
the only picture we got
what do you mean it's photoshopped look
if you sit at home and you're watching
this and you're ugly
stop worrying about your looks get up
and go change the world
i've been calvin evans it's my time